welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Ant-Man in the wasp quantumania
in the final weeks before its release
has released 16 of 10 official posters
some for Marvel Studios some done in
collaboration with other Distributors
but all of them sharing some interesting
visual themes that really surprised me
some even containing a few details
unlocking some key truths about this
story in this video I'm gonna break down
all 16 posters for the interesting
visual Secrets it's something we like to
do here at new rockstars ahead of Marvel
movies and our mission to break down
everything but for a more pointed film
analysis experience subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive in which I'll be
sharing some weekly investigations into
films that you love launching the same
day as guanamania on February 17th okay
let's start with Marvel Studios official
poster released with the trailer last
week aesthetically I think that's my
favorite just in terms of layout and the
old school painted texture of all the
characters but a few things to point out
for this one on the right on a floating
Crag is that glowing cylinder headed
figure with the staff who I think might
be associated with the Freedom Fighters
group that's the one led by Katie
O'Brien's character gentura and might be
associated with William Jackson Harper's
telepath character quays or quas or quas
but I think that guy with the staff
might actually be David Des malcian's
character web b-e-b since death maltron
is not playing Kurt in the sequel he's
gonna be playing a new character and so
that there's no confusion I'm guessing
it's going to be a CGI character but
also in this poster behind them is a
brush stroke version of one of those
orange flowing energy columns that we've
seen throughout the trailer which I
think might be part of the natural
energy resources that King has been
drilling baby Drilling in the fields of
the quantum realm which has a bandage
and Taurus people and antagonizes them
against Kang I'm gonna go more into this
in another video coming soon but to the
left side of the poster is the pyramid
shaped structure that we've seen in
several trailers but with the point of
that pyramid now glowing like a star
this was the detail I went into in my
recent breakdown of the IMAX 4K footage
now in the recent trailer that part of
the pyramid was turned off and decolored
compared to previous trailers but in
this poster in fact many of the posters
this structure appears again and again
and again and the tip of the pyramid is
always lit for all of them the fact that
we're seeing the structure so much makes
me wonder if the rings that float up
around this pyramid are actually not
part of it but maybe the mechanism
connected to the giant golden bands that
Scott is trying to shrink and steal
these bands could activate this entire
pyramid as part of Kang's ship a vast
battle ship they can move through time
the chair that we see them in might
actually be the cockpit of that ship
moving on to the next poster before the
trailer released last week the studio
released another poster with just Scott
hoping Cassie facing right and Kang
facing left behind them in an overall
more militarized vibe to it like this is
the only poster that Kang only appears
in armor and helmet and surrounding them
are all the fighters of Kang's Fleet and
to the right over Herb's shoulder is
that manta ray looking creature that
Janet rides around but framed within
Scott's chest a war is breaking out at
the base of the pyramid structure next
Empire magazine had a cover that framed
all the major characters in the palm of
King's hand Realty 3D had perhaps most
visually busy poster framing it all in
glowing hexagons and angular lines oh
hexagons are old friends it is worth
noting that ants and all insects have
six legs and this hexagonal structure
was something specific to yellowjacket
and Darren cross's company so this
actually might be the only
representation of Modoc we get in these
posters but also around some of the
elements created by the lines is that
circular written language of the quantum
realm that we spotted on the golden
bands this is the only poster to have
this language the fact that Kang or the
quantum realm has his own written
language is pretty important now I
notice some folks your brains are just
gonna merge it with the look of the 10
rings when they light up or the writing
on kamala's bangle but this is an
entirely separate language that is based
on a circle in the quantumania set chair
Peyton Reed tweeted last year it used
English letters with circles added to
each letter so if you just isolate the
circle from it you get an English letter
but that's not the case with the similar
writing on this poster and in the
trailer it seems to be more ruining I
was just out of the country of my
honeymoon and I went on Netflix over
there and I was shocked to see all the
stuff that normally is there in American
Netflix but not where I was that's why
it's so important to use nordvpn with
nordvpn I can switch my virtual location
on my device with one click letting me
access streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost this opens up
a smorgasbord of stuff to watch that I
wouldn't be able to access without
nordvpn nordvpn is also the fastest VPN
out there so you won't have to sacrifice
speed for sake of your shows it's what
we use at new Rockstar's offices let me
tell you it's fast for the price of just
one cup of coffee a month I get to have
premium cyber security on six devices
and and gain access to streaming
services from over 60 countries at no
extra cost it's also available on every
platform to grab your exclusive nordvpn
deal go to nordvpn.com new rockstars to
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus a bonus gift nordvpn is a
30-day money-back guarantee so you can
try nordvp and completely risk-free just
click the link in the description to get
started now the IMAX poster is the only
group one that features Bill Murray's
character Lord krylar but on the right
side of the poster I think that is the
guy that I think is beb and to the left
of him I think that's gen Torah right
next to him then a screen X poster that
looks really cool just mostly for the
way Jonathan Majors is framed as Kang
down the center of this poster is a blue
particle stream but when it reaches
Kang's face it aligns with the scar
stretching down the right side of his
face then a Dolby poster that features
all the characters with an interesting
alignment on Scott's helmet and Hope's
helmet red and yellow with smaller Scott
framed in his eyepiece in a smaller hope
in her eyepiece Kang is both in the
upper right but then a smaller form of
him is in the Middle with its time chair
or what I think might be the cockpit of
his Battleship up by Scott's head is
that interesting location we've seen
very little of from the trailers it's a
red illuminated area with what looked
like crashed ring structures this may be
the wreckage of Kang's Battleship that
he's trying to repair on this poster
down by Hank Pym is a rock structure
with four figures which I think is some
combination of those Freedom Fighters
one of them could be William Jackson
Harper's quads this poster is actually
pretty similar to the Fandango poster
which is basically this background
without the characters added but here
you can better see an interesting
texture in the lower right corner which
looks like a cellular structure under a
microscope interesting for a movie that
takes the microscopic and makes it
macroscopic then a 4dx poster that
features Scott with smaller versions of
a hope and Cassie around his head
directing them where to go but then the
final seven posters are official
character posters from Marvel Studios
Scott hope Kang Cassie Janet Hank and
krylar at the center of each of these
are two figures I think Scott and hope
surrounded each of these characters are
distorted versions of their faces in a
fluid ribbony design pattern stretching
out from them looking a lot like the way
Scott's giant man variant unravels out
of existence in those crazy trailer
shots while in the posters this is less
than announced for Scott and for hope it
is really evident for Kang and Cassie
and some of the others I previously
pointed out how visually this evokes
what it looks like when the Scarlet
Witch unraveled the body of Reed
Richards but you know in that case I
think she had to string cheese him
because Reed's body is elastic but in
this movie I like the idea that every
being every variant in Multiverse is
really a tightly coiled bundle of
timeline energy so to truly eradicate or
to prune someone from existence you must
unravel that knot into loose string
which one of these is your favorite
poster another reminder to subscribe to
the Deep dive launching February 17th
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at a boss follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
foreign
[Music]